ok we're going to be changing the david
pakman show podcast image and twitter
image we have if you're watching this
picture here has been the default david
pakman show podcast image for many many
years and tyler Twombly and his
girlfriend got in touch because they
felt that this was very very outdated
not the right vibe and you know what I
tend to agree so Tyler has put together
two new options for the podcast
thumbnail image and I would like
audience input okay to vote just email
me david david pakman.com or use the
contact form at david pakman.com there's
two versions one which is more cartoony
and one which is a picture okay this is
the first one which I'll put up for you
which we were calling the picture
version okay so if you like this as a
square podcast image for the david
pakman show podcast we are referring to
this as the picture version next we have
the cartoon version which is a cartoon
ified version of my face and if you like
this one better you can just email me
david at david pakman.com or use the
contact form at david pakman.com and say
you want the cartoon version i like both
of these pat and i don't i don't want to
say if i had a preference I wouldn't say
what it is because I don't want to taint
the voting pool I have a clear
preference but yes there was a lot of
talk about outside influences affecting
the 2016 election yeah I don't want to
be Russia in this scenario absolutely
not now I am NOT going to take the FSB
KGB Putin role in this entire thing so
we've got the picture version we've got
the cartoon version new podcast
thumbnail big decision thanks to Tyler
for putting these graphics together
email me david at david pakman.com and
tell me whether you prefer the picture
or the cartoon and if you're listening
please check out this segment on our
youtube channel so you can see what it
is that we're talking about